good afternoon it's a great pleasure to
speak at this Workshop where we have
such an incredible mix of people uh
coming from all kinds of directions so
to ranging from very very general
abstract Theory almost bordering on
philosophy to Great experimental
Sciences we have biologist we have heard
in David's talk just a few moments ago
um and before that we have seem very
abstract but I think very important
framework from Steve Frank so what I'm
going to discuss today is uh somewhere
in my view right in the middle uh it's
primarily and mostly uh analysis of gen
of empirical comparative genomic data
but with some
generalizations some excursions into
Theory and even into philosophy as as
you will see so basically I'm going to
describe two three
generalizations of what I consider among
the major models and major major
concepts of molecular Evolution um
namely the the con the very concept of
the genome and how we generalize on that
the concept concept of the tree of life
and how this
changes and the concept of molecular
clock and how this also may be
replaceable by something more gener and
my main point uh basically is to try and
convince you
that this the conceptual
shifts in evolutionary biology that I
think are in the making are very much
data driven genomics drives evolutionary
biology away from the useful but old
rigid constraints and models that are
becoming outdated to models that are
effectively based on statistical
properties of ensembles of genes and
genomes so I I probably have included
here too much stuff to to actually
discuss uh during this talk I think
everyone wants to have the reception so
it would be inhumane um and I'll mostly
concentrate on this first part on the on
the what I consider to be a paradigm
shift for or at least in microbial
Evolution from genomes to P genomes to
what I call the gene universe and there
is here there's quite a bit of new stuff
that I really want to share and the rest
is largely published business so I will
go through that very briefly so anyhow
um in the uh 20th century the way people
talked about Evolution the way people
described Evolution
was primarily based on the evolutionary
history philogyny of individual genes
such as above above all 60 srna a
universal highly conserved molecule that
was considered to
be the best model
for reconstruction of the history of
life or the tree of life if you
will well in the 1990s due to the new
thanks to the new technologist or we
have become aware of the
of the genomes and of the different
evolutionary histories of various parts
of the uh genomes finally these days in
the second decade of the third
millennium um we have to replace I think
the notion of the genome with the notion
of the P genome it will become clear
what this means uh during the rest of
the of this talk but basically basically
the P genome is the entirety of the of
the genes that is available to a
particular group of of
organisms primarily this is used when
the speak of microbes but actually it's
a very general concept the entirety of
the genes that is available to let's say
to be more concrete to a species so in
other
words
basically the the concept of the
microbial
P genome is well described in the
abstract of this nice paper a bacterial
species can be described by spun genome
which is composed of a core genome
containing genes present in all strains
and a quote unquote dispensable genome
containing genes present in two or more
strains and genes unique to single
strains given that the number of unique
genes is vast the pong Genome of a
bacterial species might be orders of Mag
just might be orders of magnitude larger
than any single
genome so that's that's the
idea where is the reality the reality is
that pong genomes of different microbial
species are different and and this is
Illustrated here by the
by the pomes of two well characterized
bacterial species pillos andrais and
stripto cus a galactic and you can see
that as strains this this is the number
of strain genome sequence and this is
the size of the P pomes the number of
genomes discovered so to speak by uh uh
sorry by uh uh these uh genomes you can
see that they are drastically
different these uh P genos while in
stripto
cus when
new genomes are being genomes and new
strains are being sequenced the number
of discovered genes the size of the P
genome grows grows and
grows in this case at least without
visible signs of saturation um usually
this called an open p genome if you try
to extrapolate from this it's sort of
infinite although of course nothing is
the the the Earth is finite itself so
nothing can be literally infinite but we
don't see the signs of saturation for
these open p genomes this is
dramatically different after sequencing
a few strains you basically don't
discover anything new uh so this is a
closed P genome in
practice in in real genomic
sequencing the considerable majority of
of
the P genomes seem to be more like this
than like this more open than closed we
shall towards the end of this part we
shall come to the estimates that may
show you
how how large actually how V
these seemingly open pom actually might
be question please can the notion of
poms be defined for
mammals yes of course and does it grow
as the first one or the
second I I I I would have to just get it
done
certainly you don't have to go far David
already presented in his talk evidence
that there are pongos that are bigger
than than any individual genomes by
showing the birth of a new Gene and we
have heard about birth of new genes um
previously even during uh this U uh
Workshop My suspicion my suspicion my
intuition is that it is not quite like
this it's more in between but sort of
close sort of closed but but I but I
haven't done the
analysis
okay
so so from from the P Genome of the
species we actually can go further and
look in a certain sense U at the
structure of the gene universe and the
by Gene or genomic Universe by genomic
Universe I mean the entirety of all
genomes on the planet and of course we
can try to look at some kind different
depths in this genomic Universe we can
try to look at small neighborhoods large
neighborhood and some representation of
the entire universe so if we try to do
so U at U uh different levels and make
plots like this where here the
horizontal axis is the number of
organisms in which a
gene is presented or to be precise by
Gene I mean a cluster of Aros
genes which which may be called the same
gene in all genomes that have it so the
number of genomes in which a gene is
represented and the number of gen of
genes that are represented in exactly
this number of
genomes so when we do this Gene
frequency plot for a representative set
of the entire procaryotic part or of the
U genomic Universe we detect this
tripartite structure so stepen his talk
showed us a variety of beautiful and not
so
beautiful distributions those were
however all simple
all representing apparently single
attractor here we have something more
complicated it roughly can be described
by three um exponential functions that
correspond to the tiny highly conserved
core of nearly um Universal genes by
much larger part that I fancifully call
the Shell of these genomes about two
orders of magnitude bigger and by
something that I call a cloud which is
even much bigger here I included only
the genes that are represented in at
least U uh
two genomes if you include the orphans
those that are found in a single genome
the cloud will be really big in this
case the more interesting part of this
and that can
I is this reasonably insensitive to
where you put the cut off of defining
genes as being in the same category or
is it yes this this is very insens this
is actually highly robust to this
and I'm not just just hand hand waving
we we have done it in in at very
different levels of crud death the you
will see the same kind of
thing in addition
to being highly Rob to that um and less
Tri um this structure recapitulates at
any level of at any depth at which you
would like to to peer into the genomic
Universe you can peer as far as you can
you can limit yourself to a one domain
of that Universe let's say ARA and the
slopes of these exponents the sizes of
these parts will be different but the
tripartite structure sort of a
symmetrical u-shaped distribution will
come up inevitably whatever you do and
this is practically a p genome according
to the um uh previous definitions um
pretty much this is pretty much at the
level of a single uh species and you'll
see the same kind of tripar structure
and you will see more of these so so I
like to speak of a fractal structure of
the um procaryotic Gene Universe because
this structure repeats itself at all
different uh levels incidentally I think
this was first explicitly published in
this book that also contains a number of
other ideas on
Evolution all right um just to just to
give you an additional perspective on
the diversity of the on the on the
structure and diversity of the um Gene
Universe here I put together uh this
Gene frequency PL um for the cellular
part of this universe and for the viral
part as you will as you can
see uh they're quite different here you
do not effectively have this tripartite
organization this part is severely
pretty much completely suppressed in
Decay there is this part is greatly
enhanced uh indicating that
The Bu of viral genes is even much
faster than that or the uh genes of um
cellular organisms
but this fascinating part of the uh Gene
universe is for a different talk and in
what in what FS I will discuss that
other part and first ask this question
where does the universal fror
architecture of the gene univers skewed
U shape distribution of Gene frequences
uh come
from so order to U get some handle or on
on the answer we developed something
that they call the Sgt stationary genome
on a Tre and that's a computational
model
that limits the changes of genomic
genome size to some small margin that
is that is realistic in the case or
reasonably realistic in the case of
micro
Evolution and simulates Evolution a long
defined evolutionary tree by taking
genes from an infinite Reservoir and
replacing
U uh the genes in your evolving uh
genomes under different models and the
simplest one is the neutral model
neutral in the sense that all genes have
the same replacement rate and then
models of selection with different
levels of complexity selection in this
case
means that genes differ in their value
so to speak for the evolving genomes
that is in the replacement rates we can
take a gamma distribution of replacement
rates we can take a two class model or
where there important genes and
unimportant genes so to speak um and we
can take something a little bit less
unrealistic where replacement rates are
taken from a stochastic population
model and this the ratio of the
population size to genome size becomes
the measure of selection strength um and
then we do apply this to real data from
a number of microbial groups and here
there is there these different cut
offs come into play because this was
done somewhat different
approach than the distributions I showed
previously and this does not really
change at least in terms of the general
shape
so when they fit the predictions of
these well the results of the model
Evolution under each of these models to
the empirically observed distribution
you can see immediately that U the
neutral model that these red
symbols do do a really bad job by not U
properly modeling the highly concerned
classes at all well in
order to compare different models with
selection we have to apply something um
slightly more sophisticated in this case
the Aki information criteria another
information uh criteria and what I put
here is the uh
difference is the advantage of these
models over the neutral model in this in
this case the advant for each of these
models the advantage is absolutely
overwhelming it translates to the
probability of this happening by chance
to to to pathological probability of
this happening by chance 10 to Theus 200
or something but we also can see that
the more complex selection model wins
with statistically significant margin
over the very simple toy implementations
of uh selection so sorry can you go back
to the previous slide because I don't
understand what we're supposed to be
looking at the previous one I don't
looking at here as far as which is data
and which is oh yeah yeah yeah sure sure
sure sure sure sure sure uh the the the
the the the histograms are empirical
data the these black columns the class C
that is meaning something you didn't
introduce that before
oh yeah it does it doesn't matter this
simply the number of
genomes what we did was taking groups of
10 genomes and ploted these frequency
distributions the continu
distribution yeah that's that's correct
these genes these are absolutely in
terms of this group absolutely conserved
genes those that we find in than genomes
these are the least concerned those we
find in one genome and everything in
between and for organis where you know
the the phogy yes I think you know the
pH absolutely we we have some confident
phogy for these
organisms okay so the the conclusions
from this is or the conclusion from this
is that unlike some other Universal
distributions of genomic
variables again com back to Steve's talk
today um uh
this tripartite distribution is
substantially affected by selection in a
sense if using the same language I dare
say uh that this is not aggregation of
random noisy random variables alone the
sub this substanti there is substantial
modulation over this that we can
detect all
right now again I want to
describe in a certain sense what we
described there was the Statics of this
um genomic Universe what I now want to
uh discuss is some new new data on the
that that I think give us some insight
into the genome d Mi and allow super
genome size
estimation
um so in order to do this analysis what
we used is the soal
atgc database which we developed a few
years ago and continue updating I think
this is a useful thing atgc doesn't
stand what what for what you think it
stands it rather stands for a l a line
able tight genomic
clusters and these are clusters
of related fairly closely related
procaryotic genomes that not only didn't
evolve from each other very far in terms
of signal that
have that are specifically not saturated
in terms of of KS of synonymous
positions but it also maintain a
substantial degree of Gene synony um
very uh similar related gen for instance
um just just just to be specific all the
equalized strains and Shela strains will
be in the in onec but s to which we
compared on one of the preceding slides
is already part of a different
adgc um
uh
so what we do what we do then um is the
evolutionary reconstruction for the
comparison of of these gen basically
there this this is not not so critical
we do some comparisons with this but
these two components are essential we
make species three in this Case by using
a concatenated alignment of conserve
genes for each
atgc and then we make this Matrix of
Gene presence absence in this case I
don't say Gene but I say Cog cluster of
Aros
genes and the so one side of this Matrix
are species or
STS that belong to a given ageny the
other um
side are the um crossers of arous genes
or you may say simply genes and you put
zero here if the the corresponding Gene
is not represented in
the in the given genome or or you put
one if it's
represented one paralog or two if it's
represented by two paralogs and so on
and so forth then this allows for
evolutionary reconstruction that
primitively can be done done by maximum
parsimony and a bit less primitively can
be done by maximum likelihood of certain
genomic a by obtaining likelihood of
certain or the rates likelihood maximum
likelihood estimates of the rates of
certain genomic events such as Gene gain
duplication and gross I will speak about
this in the slide greater detail in a
moment specifically we use the software
callede M likelihood software called
count developed by our collaborator mik
chus from the University of
Montreal uh so this maximum likelihood
model maximum likelihood reconstruction
is based on this very simple model that
however I think is is very important for
understanding the evolution of genomes
and Gene feminist the birth and death or
sometimes we say birth death and
Innovation model of um Gene family
Evolution it's it's extremely
um uh
simple basically have these three rates
here the death rate the birth
rate of of a g gen family and the
expansion and reduction rate in this
case
the the reduction the gene death rate is
the same is set to be the same for
families of all size
so so it's the same parameter and uh
genes new families come from the um
super
genome from this bucket that is the the
super genome so here I try to
distinguish between the two terms P
genome which is the totality of the disc
discovered
genome disc discovered genes namely that
that is an
observable quantity and the super genome
which is a sort of a hypothetical or
quantity the entire reservoir of
available G the limit of to be
the P genome
PS so so C here is the rate of gaining
this particular uh uh Gene family not a
random one just that that one right
there yes indeed um
so so ASV it it's it's it will be
important it's not really important for
for the model but it will be important
for conclusions to realize uh that
family gain effectively occur
biologically corresponds to
horizontal Gene
transfer whereas
this denotes the process of Gene
duplication so you'll see the
relationship
between
this these processes so we derive these
maximum likelihood estimates of the
rates of of all of these processes and
on this slide I plot this against the
branch length or in other words the
number of
substitutions per site and so this
measures Mo the ticking of the um
genomic clock and we see that there is a
strong positive correlation here between
the number of gains number of losses and
expansions and reduction
and the branch length so there is this
correlation is weak these are strong but
in each case um there is a significant
um clock like behavior of each of these
processes suggestive of an important
neutral component in these evolutionary
processes but there is something else
um to which uh I want to bring uh your
attention um and um uh this this is the
number
of events G or Gene family gains or Gene
family losses or per nucle substitution
so you see that then the evolutionary
distance is let's say 120th of a
substitution per nucleotide a very short
evolutionary distance you already have
for that short evolutionary distance
hundreds of these different events
hundreds or dozens of these different
events
so what we have already seen is that the
genomic D genome Dynamics is rapid one
two there is a COR like Behavior another
very striking observation that I still
cannot fully to terms it but it it
appears completely robust and observable
in
many in many of these groups is the
extreme variability of genome Dynamic
rates so to speak lifestyles of microbes
may vary from extremely squalid and
boring to highly turbulent the these
rates um differ um by several orders of
itude and so do the ratios of
these of these different events but like
what organism to what organ or like what
family to what
family I don't I cannot say so or we
have in this in this collection in what
has been analyzed we have 34 distinct
classes of of Bia and one arill both
available we do we analyze everything
that is currently available in terms of
the sufficient number of closely related
strains and they cover much of bacterial
diversity I cannot say that I see much
Rhyme or Reason in the biological
sense in these strongly varying race
that is we cannot say that let's say
prot bacteria are highly Dynamic whereas
Grand positive bacteria
are very
static or or
even parasites are highly static whereas
three living organism are highly Dynamic
not so there are differ but they're
fairly subtle these huge variations are
not explained in this straightforward
manner how do you know that a lot of the
variations aren't from variations the
mutation rate rather than um variations
in the Do Not turnover
rates um I am not so sure Danel what do
you mean now by by mutation rates what
so you you you when you say a clock so
that your clock is the number of
synonymous rate of synonomous
substitutions right
oh well yes oh the the yes um one one
one part
is what we measure are there these
events against syal subtit right so
substitution rates can vary by fact of
100 so I mean I mean I don't believe
this hypothesis but one hypothesis is
that the turnover of the genomes is
similar but the mutation rates are very
different well yes this is this is this
is relative to the okay this is relative
to to the substitution rate indeed but
you have to keep in mind that these are
short evolutionary
distances these C relatively short
evolutionary evolutionary time so I we
did not measure here we did not try to
measure the variation of the act or or
the sequence Evolution quock here we
just took it as a standard I do not
think however that along such short
branches DS would vary by two orders of
magnitude I would sus I was very much
suspect because all of the phies are
analyzed under the assumption it doesn't
vary okay but that this is a technical
question this is very technical question
but again the these these are very short
evolutionary distances of course
the genomic the the sequence Evolution
cor is not precise here but they
actually know that DN over DS is quite a
stable feature Within These at these
small groups so I think it called
question yes do you think the statistics
can be highly skewed toward genomes that
can be cultivated and non-cultivatable
genome may have more turbulent life
because they have to live together
otheres no I do not
oh there is always this issue but I do
not think so because um uh here we have
a huge representation of Lifestyle
parasites and and free living or the
parasites that live in relative
isolation things that live in our guts
in in those microbiomes things that live
in the sea or things that like AR or
that are not parasited but live in
isolation in Yellow Stone pools and so
on and so forth so far you know whenever
someone managed to cultivate something
that was not cultivable before this
organism is interesting but it is not
qualitatively qualitatively different
from the accountable ones so no I don't
think this is a huge issue okay how much
this be sensitive to sampling biases in
different types so for example around
the you know EOL are like usually over
sampled and if they just in their
ecology they end up picking up or
droing and they're
oversampled would skew your estimate as
opposed to somewhere else where you have
a single representative of course we
cannot do anything with single
representative or or or two
Representatives we start from I believe
10 and you you're right that there are
very many more equal but I can just tell
you this does not depend on the size of
the group it simply does not
correlate all right I I think I have to
proceed faster because I want to tell
you quite a few more
things and not to keep it from the
reception for too
long u so in in any case there is this
huge still to a large extent unexplained
variability but then there also these
relationship that while also namely the
ratios between loss and gain reduction
and expansion or gain and expansion and
so on and so forth and here we see two
and these vary but they very less and we
and when we look at the modes of these
distributions or medians of these
distributions or whatever we actually
start seeing striking things namely that
the ratio of L to gain typically is
greater than one the genomes lose more
genes or more families than they gay
this is already interesting what is I
think especially dramatic in Striking is
that there in order of magn no this
order of magnitude more gains of fness
than expansions remember horizontal Gene
transfers versus duplication there are
order of magnitude more of of horizontal
transfers versus
duplication and there is also an order
of magnitude more of loss of Gene
families than there are reductions so
this puts a very specific qualitative
aspect on these Dynamics it's very much
about loss and acquisition of new
families as already touched upon we can
look along the diversity of of the
microbes and
see considerable conservation of these
Trends with variability of course
especially in terms of the rate of
L actually what we tried to do is a very
crude estimate of course and of
to a large extent as a matter of of fun
was to date these events linking genome
Dynamics uh to real time using the
estimates coming from your Senor P from
dated your Senor PES Evolution from
comparison of the cative agent of a
Justinian plague in the 6th Century to
Modern I
Ates so these are Cod estimates but I
think they give us an idea and that idea
is striking so we have so these are
values per thousand
years more than 10 events of these kinds
per thousand years in other words in the
entire microbal world a huge number of
genes are L and gained on on a time
scale commen with our lifetime of course
anecdotally we already know about that
form antibiotic resistance and such
things interestingly enough these R
rates show significant decline the
phenetic deps indicating that many gains
losses expansions and reductions
actually are transient are not really
fixed in the
population now we also notice uh that
Gene family gain and expansion rates do
positively correlate with the pound
genome sides not the size of the super
genome so far we don't really know about
that but the size of the actually
discovered P genome so that at least
Rhymes the reason U so we have greater
rates of gain or corresponding to larger
P
genomes what we also see is a general
genome flux Trend in other words the
rates of all these events including
rates of gains and loss uh and losses
are positively and significantly
correlated you could think that there
are primarily gainers and losers among
evolving genomes and and while such
things certainly exist some are gainers
some are losers that seemingly is is not
the main distinction the main
distinction seems to be between Dynamic
and static
ones so we do the PCA in the genomic
event space and it's it's it's it's
fairly striking because the first
principle comp
component in this case explains over 70%
of the um variation which is something
that you rarely see when you um in my
experience which is not inconsiderable
you rarely see in the in in comparative
genomics and uh
this first uh component corres seems to
correspond to the general genomic
flux
all all these very original variables
contribute in the same direction and
significantly to this
pc1 so this
pc1
represents visibly what I already
pointed out that the main Trend in
genomic evolution is the level
the magnitude of this overall flux the
second the second principle component
that is also significant is the balance
indeed the relative contributions of U
uh gain uh and gain and expansion loss
and reduction so that's the difference
between gainers and
losers and the final uh thing in this
story um is the promised um super genome
size estimation you could this is very
simple approach in the there different
ways to do so of different levels of
complexity and we working with that this
is a very
simple
approach which you could already guess I
think um we do that from the uh
incidence of
multiple uh games U so if the simplest
approach is such that every time a
family is gain drawn a trender from a
well mixed super genome I will now use
the term super genome for that Reservoir
and then you can easily um estimate or
easily obtain the maximum likelihood
estimate of s we can use a slightly more
um sophisticated approach when the gain
probability varies between different
fams and use different distributions for
that or I wouldn't go into the details
of this the difference is not huge but
the results are are consistent and
interesting this is under uniform gain
probability distribution this is and
power low gain probability uh
distribution for the substantial
majority of these groups there sort of a
new constant emerging if you will the
size of the super genome is roughly an
order of magnitude greater than the size
of the typical genome granted there are
several groups for which as far as we
can see the super genome is remains open
it's quite huge but the typical Trend in
the microbial world seems to be this so
the super genome is all the ones in that
group the super all bacterial genes the
super genome is a bit of an abstract
musal it is the entirety of the genes to
which let's say eoli or all strains of
eoli have access in the course of the
evolution it's bigger than the Pome
right everything that could get then why
isn't it all bacterial I mean why isn't
it all bacterial
genes to give you a trivial example
Haven seen to give to give you a trivial
trivial trivial illustration of that um
I do not really believe that over the
course of of its Evolution eoli ever had
the excess any kind of direct access to
Hy hyper thermophilic habitats and the
genes that are typical for those
habitats
so it's not the entire genomic universe
or or or it's or to be to be more
precise of course there you may say that
this is the entire genomic
universe and there is some probability
density function over all genes but it
but in practice its values are
indistinguishable from zero for the
great majority of them that that that's
that's that's the statement in a more
more realistic terms since the model has
a fix I mean there some weighted measure
over this which is in practice what
you're estimated yeah right
in you may you may you may you may you
may say that they're estimating the
apparent size of the super genome how
they how the reservoir looks from the
incidence of repeated gains within this
model within there isn't much of a model
here
actually oh this this is yeah yes with
yeah within the maximum likelihood model
of gen genome Evolution and
construction so
basically some conclusions from this the
genome dyam are
extremely variable but typically are
rapid rapid means rapid there are
thousands of genomic events per one
nucleotide substitution per nucleotide
and many even per one one nucleotide
substitution in the entire genome
several at
least on average Ross has a higher rate
is more common than gain and
dramatically more common than expansion
of reduction of fness horizontal Gene
transfer in other words from this
horizontal Gene transfer along the gene
loss shapes the
genomes all rates are correlated so Gene
fux is the key determinant of genome
Evolution typically the super genome is
about 10 times the genome but some super
genome seem to be vast but I think there
are also General implications of this
rapid genome
Dynamics and to me actually I must
confess that I added this slide during
this Workshop it was not there in the
talk that I prepared but I was induced
to do so compelled to do so by the
repeated discussion of Darian Evolution
here Darian model of evolution of course
Darian concept is not one thing it's
quite a few it's several important
statement but what we see here that
Evolution does not proceed by
infinitesimally small changes and here
is the rather famous quote from Dar not
the most famous but rather famous quote
from P original species if it could be
demonstrated that any complex organ
existed which existed which could not
possibly have been formed by numerous
successive like modifications my theory
would absolutely break down so Charles
Darwin parenthetically was a great prar
he already knew that the important thing
about the theory is to is falsify FAL
falsifiability um
so this
tet I think is effectively falsified it
is not that okay you don't think so
well it says complex organ it doesn't
say the basis of heritability there's a
distinction between genomes and all
right okay take it take it there is a
distinction there is a there is there is
a well okay you know all right all right
all right I think a bacterium and a
qualifies as a complex
organ think that way oh no he oh he
simply did not think in that direction
period I think he
I think he would have been struck by the
complexity of these organism especially
their communities so what we see here is
that it's not that these not are not the
only types of events that occur these
not the most by far not the important
events that
occur so I think the issue is not so
much whether complex adaptations could
or could not have been formed by
consecutive Point meds but that they
have not been at least in this part of
the B and here I have finished this part
of my talk and already overdone the time
and there are two more important parts
so I will not of course go through them
in the entirety but I'll simply say a
few words about each basically the phog
genetic Forest of light and that signals
in the evolution of procar uh so
nowadays we have transitioned as I as as
I showed in one of my initial one of my
first SES from the study of the
evolution of one standard right 16 sna
to the study of evolution of huge
ensembles of genes they show different
phog so the goal of this part of the
study B to see whether or not there is
some order in this Forest of life there
or not whether or not there are some
detectable patterns I I have to go
through all of this this was a detailed
analysis of thousands of phenetic trees
for procaryotic
genes and the conclusions simply are the
conclusions are that there is a common
central evolutionary Trend in this
Forest of
life so to to to put it
to encapsulate it in a tired aism the
Tree of Life Is Dead long live the tree
of
life so in the topologist of these trees
we can see substantial significant order
that can be approximated by the Trees of
what I call nuts nearly Universal trees
and these are or the trees for highly
conserved genes including components of
the translation system so by the
quantitatively the three of the 16 srna
only shows a small part of evolution in
the genomic Universe it was not a bad
choice it does represent some cental T
this is on very large scale is it this
is now this is on very large scale on
the on the on the scale of the entire
the entire diversity of bacteria
and there many many curious details but
unfortunately I cannot do that or the we
manag to develop a methodology to
estimate the contribution of the this
three like signal and the net like
signal the horizontal transfer and
roughly speaking it's one to two one
vertical
signal 13 vertical signal 23 horizontal
signal so that's that and the last part
which I will touch upon very very
briefly the Universal pacemaker of
genome Evolution General model to
replace molecular clocks of of course we
have t already a little about molecular
clock everyone everyone knows what that
is everyone I think in this room knows
that it's over dispersed and
therefore uh people speak people now
mostly deal with models of relaxed
molecular clo what we did was going
further uh than that m and what we
proposed is that the con conservation of
these
distributions okay that we have seen
these are L normal distributions and we
have seen such in talk today and these
are the genomic distributions of The
evolutionary rates of arous gen they're
strikingly concerned strikingly
similar from from bacteria to m I think
that the conservation of the shape of
the amount of variation in these
distributions might not be a trivial
consequence of aggregation so what is
this the distribution of okay the
relative evolutionary rates of arous
genes and this is a
probability density function simply so
this is for bacterium this is for humans
this is for a couple of fun
so you take these rates over the entire
set of Aros genes in a pair of related
genomes and you Pro the distribution the
rates being the DN Sy DS oh you can you
can do DN over DS you can do DM you can
do DS only only the rdth of the
distribution will
change this is this this the
specifically these are am substitutions
but you can do the same with TS
they they're narrow but you can do the
same
so given the over dispersal molecular
clo we thought of hypothesize that this
is not a trivial consequence of
molecular clo and perhaps something that
is more important than molecular clo and
might replace it or would be something
that we denoted the universal Pac maker
of genomic Evolution namely the model
Accord According to which it's the
relative rate of Gene Evolution not the
absolute rate with respect to
astronomical time but the relative rate
of genes with respect to each other that
is conserved in the course of genomic
Evolution and then we developed the
framework
to compare to
determine which models better fit phenis
a molecular clock model or the universal
BAC maker model in several experiments
that we did across the diversity of life
for
bacteria and recently for ukaria we show
that the pacemaker model is
substantially I would say
overwhelmingly or better fit to the
topologies of these trees than the
molecular CL model so again from the
genomic
comparisons vary of analysis but again
from the genomic comparisons we can
see
that apparently the rigid molecular old
molecular clock model can be replaced by
more General and more flexible perhaps
somewhat less unrealistic model of um uh
genome
Evolution basically that's what I wanted
to say a tiny bit of philosophy before
the
reception first of all no first of all
this is not
philosopy I think this is this is this
whole thing is extremely data
driven we can the the theory in this
case in my view is extremely data driven
we can transition to these perhaps more
powerful models due to accumulation of
message genomic data
and I have to Pat myself on the back due
to generation of appropriate data sets
such as those atgcs for instance that
allow us to test specific
models
U
well in this philos through the
comparative study of evolutionary
histories of numerous genomes and genes
encounter this new flexible models would
are stting to incorporate original
regions worlds as special cases not
unlik I think what is going on in
physics in
general all right so Sagi near who is
here the pacemaker
man per P boy your poog in my group The
Three
Men actually the Tre men and the atgc
men Alex wovi the model man and Yuri wol
who who is a senior member of the group
contributing to all all of this here we
are in front of our building in Bethesda
thank you very
much maybe a couple of questions before
the
reception we have any or is everyone
thinking about their free
drinks yeah thanks I was even struck by
one of the first patterns you showed
there are these these bacterial species
or clusters which have these closed
genomes and the ones which are open so
what explains that in first place before
we go
to
well the first
approximation answer is I don't know the
second approximation answer is of course
I can think of a few important
factors and
and basically these factors are the
lifestyle that is the how
many how many how many how what is the
diversity of the community in which the
given
organisms
exists what what is the population
Dynamic what the population size of this
organism how much time it actually
spends effect
actively dividing rather than being
dormant
somewhere various ecological factors and
second important group of factors are
actually more mechanistic do these
organisms
possess molecular machines um such as uh
those for DNA uptake um
how to what extent they are subject to
bacteria phage attacks and so on and so
forth do they in code soal Gene transfer
agent so on and so forth do they have
the if I if I may go back to something
do they have mechanisms for evolvability
so so the closed genomes they have
generally less mechanisms and that's
your expectation to
do um uptake that that is obviously my
expectation which is something that is
that that is to some extent already
testable through the able diversity of
genomes but I must say that this
homework has not been done at least not
not not not by myself or by anyone I
know but you distinguish two kinds of
uptakes I mean uptakes within the group
and then uptakes from the super genome
which is somehow no no no no no I don't
believe so I don't believe so no I no I
do not or if I made that impression I'm
sorry oh one one could oh you
know we calling P's talk yes one could
revert to that kind of more complex Mo
model but I so far um I think we do not
have the indications to go if they found
a now well mixed model
of okay thanks very
much